this video is sponsored by expressvpn
oh breath of the wild how i love thee
except for when you're vague and
confusing then it's more of a love hate
thing
oh don't get me wrong i love stumbling
across a hidden reference or easter egg
just as much as the next guy
but i'm not the next guy i'm me a
theorist and a theorist looks at all
these landmarks and naming schemes and
you know
giant mushroom things and goes wait what
the heck
why is any of this here and what does
this mean for breath of the wild's
backstory
and one of the most hotly debated pieces
of vague breath of the wild lore would
be the
infamous eighth heroine of the seven
heroines
no i did not mess that up you heard me
correctly
of the legendary group of individuals
called the seven heroines
there exists an eighth member huh well
surely it's explained in game right
no no it isn't now if you've ever been
curious about said eighth member of the
seven you've probably stumbled across
nintendo black crisis's very successful
two-part theory on the existence and
identity of the eighth heroine and if
you haven't yet
go watch it like for real because if
there's one thing i'm not gonna do in
this video
it's cover who i think the eighth
heroine is
nah i'm just playing you kidding me i
cover
everything of course i'm gonna let you
know who i think the eighth is but to be
honest i wanna really focus on another
rather puzzling detail
about the eighth's statue and that would
be the matter of her weapon
as in her sword as in where is it
actually we know where it is
it's way up on the peak of the gerudo
summit just
casually stabbed into the ground facing
the sunrise and a lionel but that's
besides the point
my question is this how in the
world did this get all the way up here
and who would have moved
it and why would they have moved it if
you find yourself
even remotely curious about any of these
questions well
you're in luck i'm about to speculate
the crap out of this thing so let's get
started
and hey real quick would you do me a
favor take a look at that subscribe
button right there below this video
yeah yeah that one is it pressed no well
you're going to want to go ahead and
subscribe to the channel with those
notifications on because there's a lot
of
really cool nintendo stuff coming and be
sure to give this video a like if you
enjoy the content
also because i'd like you to help me
take over the world
okay cool anyway moving on like i said i
am actually going to go ahead and give
you my two cents as far as the identity
of the 8th heroine goes before we get
into the whole sword thing
now without spoiling too much of nbc's
theory videos
i'm gonna spoil them a little i can only
pray he forgives me
nbc concludes that there are two
possibilities to the identity of the
eighth heroine
link and ganondorf and i actually 100
agree with that given all the evidence
he makes until that point
however while he believes the eighth to
be a reference to link i'd actually go a
different way and say that i think it's
a reference to ganondorf instead i can
only pray he forgives me and by the way
yes
those two are a male and the heroines
are you know female but given the
gerudo's exclusively
woman race and heritage and the fact
that there probably hasn't been a male
gerudo since ganondorf
which was probably some ten thousand
plus years ago it's pretty safe to
assume that their mythological beings
would all be female
such as the eight seven heroines who are
said to be the guardians of the gerudo
anyway i think the eighth is ganondorf
because of what we know about the eighth
herself
himself themselves the eighth is said to
still
to this day have devout followers in the
gerudo highlands
your sheikah slate straight up tells you
this in the detail about the quest
but here's the kickers you know who's
located in the gerudo highlands not
gerudo that goofy yiga clan
the only people to be found anywhere
within those mountains are the
ex-shika themselves their hideout which
has that giant hole in it which by the
way i did a pretty cool theory about a
little bit ago which you should totally
go check out via the button on the top
right of the link in the description
below is located right smack dab in the
middle of the highlands
and three yiga clan members even have a
little campsite set up on the surface of
one of the mountain peaks and since it
is a
fact that the 8th heroine has current
worshippers
in the highlands to this day and the
yiga members are the only people who fit
that description
and the yiga worship and hail the return
of one
ganon but yet the heroines are said to
be the guardians of the gerudo and even
have the gerudo triangular design
patterns
all over them that leads me to believe
that the eighth heroine
represents ganon's human form ganondorf
the gerudo i doubt the ego would be
worshiping link
given that they attempt to assassinate
him every other turn and all so is my
reasoning really that simple well for
the most part
yeah but there are a couple other things
to point out that'll strengthen the
ganondorf connection
we know the gerudo made the eighth
heroine because of its
other location according to creating a
champion the yiga clan hideout actually
used to be a gerudo archaeological site
and that would probably help explain the
garuda writing all over the walls in the
first room
speaking of the first room though there
are eight statues present of the
eight heroines now as nbc points out the
seven statues out in the big worship
area read
quote the seven sages which of course
lines up with the zelda lore that most
of us are familiar with the seven sages
from ocarina of time for instance which
is the game that introduces sages to the
series
speaking from a timeline perspective of
course now for as old as the concept as
sages are
ganondorf has been hailed as evil for
just as long
but this is where i think things begin
to make sense
while most of the garuda reacted like
urbosa or naburu and were just disgusted
that an evil man like ganondorf would
defile the gerudo's noble name
remember that in ocarina of time
ganondorf had
quote his thieves not just monsters and
not hylians either
he had gerudo women that were loyal to
him
huh could this mean that not all of the
gerudo turned on him after his evil
intent was revealed to the world
following both the child and adult
timeline endings to ocarina of time he
had a few that still worshiped him and
revered him as their king maybe
what if that clan within the gerudo of
ganondorf loyalists are the ones who
maybe insisted on including ganondorf
with the seven heroines
who like previously mentioned are
defined as the protectors of the gerudo
they saw him as one of their protectors
so why not
include him maybe they were responsible
for creating the old archaeological site
and even digging in the hole in hopes of
finding
you should really watch my other theory
video but were eventually all
either run out of there or converted
away from their ganondorf worshiping
ways now i've taken more time than i
wanted to talking about the eighth's
identity
but in a nutshell because of the yiga's
location and choice of worship
i believe the eighth is a reference to
ganondorf so what the heck is up with
its location
at first i thought the eighth's statue
was moved i thought it was originally
actually down
there with the other seven on the desert
level i mean there's a perfectly sized
gap right there
the space in between the orbs and the
pedestals around the gap measures about
31 link steps wide while the other
pedestals measure about 16
meaning the gap is precisely twice as
wide as the other spaces
giving exactly the amount of room
required to fit the eighths statue and
pedestal right here so i started looking
for ways they could have maybe moved the
eighth
out of there like looking at the broken
wall right behind where the eighth would
have been
and by the way what happened to that
wall
it is huge and super solid and it's just
broken
in pieces but anyway then i went to the
actual location of the actual
eighth heroin statue introduced that
there's no way the statue came from the
land down under
why well if you look at the eighth's
statue you'll notice that along the
edges near the top
it isn't complete
and it's still joined to the rock that
it was being carved from and by the way
you'll also notice that
all the statues are probably carved rock
the entire area with the seven of them
down there was probably at one point
all just cliff's side and has all been
carved out remember these statues are
the stuff of gerudo legend
who knows how many thousands of years
have passed since their carving which
would explain all the weathering and
naturalizing that's taken place
but the 8th statue really does look like
this here is its origin
point maybe the gerudo loyalists just
wanted to make their own so they chose
the literal opposite side of their
mountain range to carve their statue
but whatever their reasoning were
finally at the question i wanted to ask
if they were carving this statue why is
the sword
up here let's take a look at the
surroundings and try to grab some hints
at the base of the sword there lies a
sword
nice but not just any sword a very fine
gerudo sword how
interesting there's also a chest with a
gerudo scimitar in it in one of the
hidden pockets along the edge of the
strange icy valley
located just a few yards to the north
and speaking of this valley-like
chasm it definitely looks like those
flattened sheets of rock were shattered
over time but used to maybe be suspended
above this hollow area
creating a walkway or building of sorts
underneath in fact
a lot of the rocks and rock wall around
here look suspiciously carved don't they
i mean just look at this really
interesting ramp that leads either to or
away from the eighth's statue this has
got to be man-made
having been hollowed out to allow access
to the statue looking at the carved rock
walls
the ex-gerudo camp the gerudo weapons
and gerudo architecture
i think this place used to be inhabited
by gerudo
why they're no longer here i can't say
but i think the evidence is definitely
there
meaning everything we see up here is
intentional
including the location of the forgotten
sword and again at first i was trying to
come up with some way that they may have
hauled the sword up to the peak of the
summit but again i couldn't come up with
why
they do this or especially how they'd
stab it in the solid rock like that
i mean look at it at the angle it's
resting there's
no way it's not firmly cemented into the
rock beneath it because it hasn't fallen
flat on its surface so then it hit me
what if
nothing was moved if you look at the
hands of any of the statues
you'll see by looking closely that their
hands are not connected to the swords
they had to have been made separately
separately looking again at the sword on
the peak
it makes sense now the angling the
strange positioning between two
hollowed-out rock walls
the sword is also incomplete it was
being carved up here to then be attached
to the eight's statue but for whatever
reason they didn't finish
either of these sculptures the statue is
still very much so a part of the rock
and the sword
being built from the top down over time
cracked and fell to its side but by then
there was enough rock and snow built up
around its base that it only leaned in
the fall and didn't twist
so in the end nobody moved anything the
gerudo just stopped building it abruptly
maybe when the yiga clan took over the
area who knows
and before i wrap up the video i had one
other
very interesting detail to point out so
you remember when i said
a couple times there that a lot of this
rock wall looks like it may have been
carved out by
people well it has the layout of the
random peaks in the highlands ever
struck you as
well a bit too random well if you take
the
you know what let me just show you
[Music]
breath of the wild you've done it again
ah the outdoors you know with everybody
staying indoors these days
sometimes i forget what they even are
are they even real this is a simulation
just the matrix
but fortunately for me i'm doing just
fine i live in the 21st century with
this little invention called
the internet
i mean you can do anything on the
internet these days
except for fly you can't fly yet
did you know that every time you use an
unencrypted internet connection to
browse social media
shop online or watch an online video
like this one the data that you're
sending and receiving for any of those
websites is literally wide open for
anybody to see
i'm not joking the ways of hacking
unencrypted internet connections are
known to every other kid out there these
days it's not rocket science
you probably need expressvpn and
espresso
what expressvpn you know the service
that provides you with the best virtual
private network giving you the privacy
that you need in this day and age
i use it when i'm at work trying to
watch the latest tv show so that my
bosses don't keep
up to date if you know what i mean but
people like you who are kind of stuck at
home these days could probably use it to
mask your ip address or even watch shows
that aren't available in your country
from your favorite streaming services
like netflix
well that sounds delightful actually
but do they have the fastest speeds 24 7
customer support
simple ease of use number one ratings
from websites like tech radar and the
verge
and do they have the physical inability
to store
any of their customers data preventing
any and
all possibilities of a security breach
[Music]
well how do i sign up expressvpn is
everything i just mentioned
and more and to top it all off it's so
easy to use that even a duns like me can
do it
eventually there you go buddy i knew you
could do it
find out how you can get three months of
this fantastic service for free by
clicking the link in the description
below
or by visiting by going online to
expressvpn.com
mnb this offers only around for a
limited time
so what are you waiting for go check
today
i hate that guy
hey guys thanks so much for watching
huge thanks to
all of my amazing supporters of which i
have some introductions in order
say a big hello to valencia 007
malon infinite curly and selena who have
all joined the ranks of my elite
thank you guys so much for inspiring me
every day
and on top of that choosing to support
the channel enjoy your benefits guys
and if you watching are interested in
getting your name up here at the end of
every video and some awesome benefits
like custom emoji
badges and more click that giant join
button or the link in the description
below to find out how
also down there are links to my social
media pages so stop on by and say hi
that's all i've got for this theory so i
guess i'll be seeing you in my next
upload
until then my friends this is mask
nintendo bandit signing out have a great
rest of your day
peace
[Music]
bye